[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir blondy j'ai travaillé pendant
dix ans val qui pendant dix ans je t'ai
vu rue des lombards ça fait combien de
temps que des gens barreau 50 à 30 ans
et j'ai jamais osé aborder dans
l'émission la télé j'étais invité
remarquer d'accord ça fait plaisir je
suis papa par imagine comme ça qu'un
jour un soir je passe dans la rue d'en
bas
depuis j'ai envie que j'ai envie de toi
oui du site aborde comme ça dans la rue
d je te dis qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est
ce que tu me proposes mais ça dépend un
jeu tout le monde d'accord ce qu'est ce
que tu veux je te fasse c'est à toi de
nous dire aussi un petit peu je peux
dire des choses un peu en vigueur l'an
passé le départ oui si tu me le demande
je les filles c'est quoi ta spécialité
mais surtout machiste ah ben oui tu peux
faire quoi tu connais fouetté par les
fouettés oui
comme tu veux que tu attaché je peux
faire et après tu ma tâche sur un lit
tout attaché sur mon avis sur une croix
en bois se trouve une croix chez toi
origine on est obligé de laisser tout le
matériel chez moi donc tu peux
m'attacher sonar en bois façon de mettre
dans un cercueil à l'occasion d'un
mariage est un circuit même dans une
cage avec moquerie grille du temps
provinces qui constituent ses courses m6
est bon et qu'est ce qui fait mal aux
jambes rihaoui a fait un bond à vouloir
mater qui borde la terre est défendable
il ya des gens qui te demanderas bay
avec nous ont demandé plusieurs le truc
le plus fou quand même que demander sa
belle c'est d'avoir ouvert n'est pas
vraiment un oui mais tu les ouvre avec
rabin ou alors j'ai un petit bijou est
une lame de rasoir sa défense je ne fais
pas ça comme vous chers bien 6 1
je sais tout vraiment je suis bon avec
terre je vais pas m'amuser à faire
brahma couteau découvrir les parties
comme ça non
georges y voilà
l'amour je le consulte je me transforme
en docteur alors je lui demande d'abord
on me fait me voir ou es ce que vous
avez vraiment mal alors il dit voilà
j'ai mal allant chez moi je fais mon
diagnostic jeux d'hiver voilà monsieur
vous avez avec piste sur une partie non
alors à me voir si vraiment il jauge de
fâches virot donne rendez-vous niveau
quand ils reviennent dit je suis
d'accord je veux tu le fasses bon a
lancé mes clients que je prends que
j'habille en infirmière moi je m'habille
en chirurgienne ils voient que mes yeux
est bon alors je transforme
l'appartement en bloc opératoire est
alors là bon ben je fais rentrer par un
unique client le malade parce que je
considère comme un malade et dès que je
prends au monde bistouri où ma lame de
rasoir automatiquement quand je pousse
mon chum une entaille hop il éjacule
alors le jeu est terminé
un bon voilà il ya combien de gens à peu
près qui pratiquent ce dicton ça c'est
des gens général qui cherchait une
sensation forte qui ne trouvent pas chez
eux ou qu'ils ont d'autres problèmes et
qui veulent se sentir supérieur voilà je
pas peur quand par exemple 1 6 les
parties d'un homme comme ça que tu
touches le sens d'attraper des maladies
maintenant un ange mitterrand gisant au
chapitre encore comme une infirmière
comme un docteur tout avec soin toutes
les stériliser les instruments
et les autorités savent que tu fais ça
je le savais mais maintenant le jeune
exercé plus j'ai arrêté parce que
quelquefois des personnages comme moi on
a tendance à venir voir quel genre de
personne que je monte alors j'ai préféré
stopper que des gens connus d'entre eux
qui me sont venues moi je ne sais pas
comment se présente pas avec une carte
d'identité chez moi mais dis donc si tu
si tu as tâche des gens sur une croix
comme t'as pas peur ce soit un peu
sacrilège au bain devient sur sa tombe
dans le domaine sacrilège c'est
l'inconscient je le fais toi tu es pas
croyant si je suis croyante j'étais lui
chez les religieuses jusqu'à 21 ans
c'est vrai je suis sorti de chez les
religieux g20 n'ont ils pas commencé
quand même pas un prêt e
quatre jours après oui c'est vrai le
premier rang que j'ai rencontré
malheureusement personam d'abord c'était
un proxénète notoire en sortant sur le
moment dans l renseignements pour une
ruche et je sortais de chez les j'avais
encore mon chapelet dans mon sac je
connaissais rien du tout c'était la
prédestination
voilà c'était ma fille mais ça choque
pas tes sentiments religieux des
pécheresses toujours les clients à qui
tu fais tout ça blondissez des clients
réguliers ou cdd clients qui
s'il dit qu'il ya un sérieux c'est pas
des gens qui rencontrent chose qui
m'avait demandé avant et puis après on
arrive mais c'est jamais arriver
quelqu'un que tu rencontres pour la
première fois te demande choses comme ça
jusqu'au ici ici un client te demande
une chose normale c'est-à-dire juste de
fermer mon normalement t'es d'accord où
tu lui dit écoutez moi je lui réponds
que c'est lassant pourrait faire autre
chose ouais tu lui dis que toi tu peux
non je dis je pourrais te faire autre
chose que toujours pareil incident mais
la lorraine s'était pas trop d'accord
nous en savons combien un truc très
compliqué style le cercle lieu sachez ne
veut pas dire la croatie des fois je
garde la personne et jean-michel une
journée ah bah oui parce que des fois il
ya des pansements à faire parce que je
rentre vraiment dans le jeu
bon ben vous quand j'ai fait des petits
points de suture que je rejoue avec une
aiguille
bon il faut que je fasse des pansements
est tout pour moi c'est un malade je le
soigne comme si j'étais un docteur voilà
je conserve chez moi de journée au juge
en fait repartir le lendemain
des fois il les gens qui restent
plusieurs jours des joueurs en génère
deux jours oui j'étais enfermé dans un
cercueil à bord oui y'en a qui restent
dans le cercueil il reste après avoir
déjà pu les oiseaux blessés de même que
me demande une journée entière ou c'est
moi même qui donne la punition ah bon il
ya eu quelque chose de pas bien fait ou
de maladies et sont à même qui renferme
la personne mais comment t'est arrivé à
faire ça enfin au début je le faisais
normalement paix après j'ai voulu me
spécialiser tout moment elle cherche une
spécialité alors je me suis retrouvé ton
prévoit la fin c'était vraiment pour moi
et dans la rue il ya beaucoup de sites
du français je suis la seule et à paris
tu pense que oui il ya beaucoup
pratiquent les gens fin sans trahir de
secret les gens qui viennent me voir
c'est plutôt des gens qui gênent
même pas rien en fin de vie voit bien
ils sont plutôt jeunes plutôt agi de
tous les âges
il ya des jeunes semaines des
championnats de 20 ans de 20 ans oui
j'ai tous les âges ces traitements par
dénoncer chaque garçon qui vit ça casse
voilà c'est tout et après tu veux faire
savoir combien de temps je ne sais pas
ça me plaît bien le faire c'est mon
métier voilà tu prends du plaisir quoi
faire ça bon je ne rentre pas dans le
jura mort mais quand même j'aime bien le
faire voilà quand on me le demande je
rentre dans mon jeu quelques fois parce
que c'est le soulage la personne je vois
juif et du bien moralement et tout est
trop tard de chez moi heureux si vous
aviez à chercher chez moi quelque chose
que comme je vous dis qu'il n'a pas
ailleurs
ou alors tu étais tout contraignant
ailleurs lorsque je lui fait subir mois
une série c'est ben il sent plus
supérieure pour affronter ce qu'ils
payent agissant de l'afup revoilà donc
tu penses tu as une fonction parce que
la vie parce que medica abri youri si
nécessaire
tu fais quoi d'autre dans la vie à part
ça je veux dire quand tu quand tu fais
passer le trail combien de jours par
semaine monde j'ai des petites erreurs
je commençais à 6 heures le matin 6h du
matin et puis jusqu'à deux heures de
l'après midi
ouais voilà pierre prévost je lis
j'écris
tu habites dans l'appartement où tu fais
ça ah non pas du tout je ferme la porte
à clé s'éterniser gens me voient là une
autre personne au journal un autre
appartement où tu terminais vissage
voilà tu arrives à mettre beaucoup
d'argent de côté quand même non pas
tellement parce que l'argent de la
prostitution au cic l argent du diable
comme voilà tu dépenses tout va mal tu
leur pardonne pas quelqu'un à vannes ont
heureusement je lui fais mais plus
maintenant
maintenant mon âge j'ai fait mes preuves
dans le métier quand même je fais un
livre riche mais j'écris la prostitution
telle qu'elle était telle qu'elle se
faisait est telle qu'elle existait voilà
comment tendre la main qg même inclinés
par la scène bien sûr celle qui a été
souillé par tout ce que j'ai pu subir
dans ma vie par l'homme fait un déjà que
nous devrons amour avec un mac
bon quand j'étais jeune les plumes est
en licence son art ses cendres mais des
fois qu'on fait un thé cliente a pas
envie non pas du tout il y en a qui te
propose de sortir de là en effet je
voudrais parce que c'est pas la peine je
me plais dans mon métier tu as des
regrets d'avoir fait ce métier pas du
tout ce qui ma foi si c'était à refaire
je referais la même chose pareille
je
[Musique]
tu peux nous dire là ce qu'ils sont
devenus les augmente de culture club là
le jaune mais cela le batteur la suie
qui avait fondé le groupe là tous les
mecs de culture club venant pas projet
toi quand tu joues un atout dans des
groupes différents
moi je me suis mis à jouer en solo à
quoi je sais pour moi je ressentais le
besoin de m'exprimer tu vois que j'ai
besoin d'une plus grande liberté aux
paroles sont là il s'appelle la
boulangerie vit où là c'est quoi la
différence avec ce que tu faisais avant
là tu peux l'expliquer aux gens qui
t'ont pas vu là j'ai appelé ça la bonne
jauge review parce qu'un autre personne
qui chante tu vois quoi il ya plusieurs
personnes qui chantent c'est un peu
comme une commune soul review quoi tu
vois je vais à des concerts
je trouvais ça vite ennuyeux toi et je
crois qu'on peut pas y aller juste voir
comme ça quelqu'un quoi il faut qu il
une variété fois tu vois c'est un peu
comme quand au théâtre il ya le
personnage principal et puis bonne tu
vois quand il ya plein d'autres
personnages et des rôles différents
corps et en libérant se chausser de
données toi leur chance à d'autres gens
qui ont beaucoup de talent mais qui
n'ont pas eu la chance de s'exprimer toi
[Musique]
ce qui est important tu as et là c'est
les jeunes tu vois moi j'ai de la chance
que tu as tu vois ce qu'il faut à la
musique c'est amuser les jeunes tu as
mangé de la chance parce que je gagne
plein de pognon là je fais un truc que
ça mais comment dire un naturel tu vois
je chante tu vois quoi je m'éclate quant
à laura je pense j'aille travailler des
fois tu à ses jours par semaine on y
voit des concerts moi je voudrais leur
donner quelque chose de drôle soit
amusant quoi les pyrales elle porte à
magnifier son bord et c'est vrai qu'un
jour les vannes il est venu voir et ya
dix ans
c'est quoi la toile à thorigné prévue lé
là et tu te dis everything as you need a
dit on va l'enregistrer
[Musique]
s'il reprises alors tu vas faire plus
que des reprises ou quoi si on regarde
l'ensemble de ma carrière j'ai écrit pas
mal de chaînes seraient de la première
reprise où que je refuse
[Musique]
c'est un tube un poisson un tube man
fait maintenant je vais écrire mon
prochain album et toutes les chaînes sur
toile durant j'ai trouvé ce travail et
de la baume
tu poses souvent l'époque où tu étais au
tabou avec trop jeune et boveri marine
et nous tirons oublier tout ça en fait
ce concert invité très spécial tu vois
que parce que c'était un anniversaire de
la mort de mon ami marc et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles le show les
bonnes parce que je suis vivant toi et
moi je suis contente d'être nuage
je célèbre la mémoire des gens que je
connaissais jeu au nom de ces gens là je
dois continuer de faire quelque chose de
positif quoique est ce qu'on sera
il était important pour moi parce que ça
fait exactement ce que j'ai perdu ma
meilleure amie
je voulais monter sur scène et donner
tout ce que je pouvais et toi tout le
monde a trouvé ça super ton dernier
album s'appelle salt et pourquoi
c'était juste une réflexion sur la
presse britannique j'ai pensé bien que
ça fait avoir avec les cantons parce que
si tu vas le daily mirror ou aux jeunes
étudient gp ou feindre une rumeur à
propos des pouilles
il l'achète et 30ml frais
vous savez ce que tu sais qui tu as
vendu auprès des gens faut pour qu'on
les citer tous
l'autre et pis ça rame et tués plutôt
sage à l'intérieur j'ai changé c'est
vrai que quand on a fait un cul
l'héroïne on peut tout faire
ça vous rend très très fort de ses
larmes plus fort mais je ne conseille à
personne de commencer à en prendre c'est
une expérience que je ne souhaite à
personne
ça fait partie de ma vie je n'ai pu par
les faussaires mais ça fera toujours
partie de mon passé je n'ai pas envie de
parler d'eux les doigts tu n'es pas
morts comme sid vicious ou james dean et
du zinc divine europe et est ravie comme
un libérateur est gratinée non ça
m'inquiète pas ça n'était inquiété par
dt dire que tu finiras dans des draps
des soirées des roses je trouve c'est
une question stupide
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tu pratique le bouddhisme
par coin ça s'est traduit dans la vie de
tous les jours le bouddhisme que c'est
vraiment la religion du 21e siècle
signes religieux el aïn côté vaches
manfra digue
il faut étudier ou bien comme parles tu
as quoi mais je vais expliquer comment
ça tu vois c'est difficile à
[Musique]
est-ce que tu n'es pas maintenant elle
n'est toxique et du beau désert non mais
je suis plus un toxique et par quoi que
ce soit maintenant moi je regrette qu'en
france nous n'ayons plus des rois est ce
que tu es un monarchiste ya plus d'une
reine d'angleterre mon souhait pareil en
france
[Musique]
je l'aï fait je laime pas vraiment la
reine d'angleterre
enfin je la préfère à éclairer le pen tu
es content avec la monarchie à
l'angleterre 1-1 ils sont trés
inoffensif il faut rien s'engage pas sur
les vraies questions soient ses
quelconque
il parie que tu aimes pokou edith piaf
je pense que c'est quelqu'un d'assez
fantastic ouais tu connais des chansons
non non non non rien de rien je ne
regrette rien non rien si on ne regrette
rien
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la semaine
c'est
[Musique]
m
je t'aime
[Musique]
tu
m
[Musique]
têtu
à tous
[Musique]
à seulement deux piscines
battus
tél
c'est ça
comme par ex
neuchâtel
[Musique]
étudier
tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
à qui
et il
[Musique]
tu
es-tu
à
[Musique]
ep
alors cela fait dix ans vous êtes
académiciens qu'aimeriez vous accueillir
sous la coupole il ya deux hommes que je
souhaiterais bois montrer à l'académie
main c'est trop tard c'est à nous pour
c'est bien dommage qu'ils ne soient pas
entrer et loteries d'état encore chance
et julien gracq refusant au générique
j'ai appris que vous appelez en fait
roger peyrefitte vous aussi de naissance
je m'appelais roger perkins avait
demandé la justice de changer le nom app
tous d'avis avant qu'ils fassent tous
ces scandales vous êtes très bien
informé la mairie avant que joueur vous
êtes vous prêt à vous passer des
journées à préparer cette émission et
puis vous me cueilli à froid dans trois
armes illégales si c'est tout à fait
parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup plus
d'expérience que moi et qu'il était
écouté c'est vrai que je m'appelais
roger c'est ne prenons pas de donner mes
parents étant donné que
les livres il faisait provoqué quelques
scandales très particulière parce qu'il
n'y avait qu'un tel est avantage à ce
que je me dissocie je me dis faire de
nuit
d'ailleurs c'était avantageux pour lui
aussi il veut pas intérêt à ce qu'on
mélange est alors j'ai changé de prénom
par un jugement du tribunal
car il faudra jugement le tribunal pour
changer de prénom et je suis devenu
alain depuis lors mais ça vous gêne
c'est moi et c'est moins visible de
changer de sexe il est quand même
difficile est devenu alors quel âge elle
a 20 ans
8 où vas tu m'as vent ça vous gênez pas
d'un seul coup de sape et alain comme ça
c'était votre deuxième prénom non non
non non c'était un prénom qui me
plaisait alors d'habitude on a le prénom
qu'on n'a pas voulu que les parents ont
choisis pour vous tandis que là j'ai
choisi mon prénom c'est un prénom
plaisait bien je trouvais que il pesait
une bonne consonance avec mon nom et je
les choisis alors comme il est très
différent de roger en me distinguer
nécessairement de lui il voyage est
d'origine il était diplomate et il était
écrivain et j'étais diplomates et je
voulais devenir écrivain elle avait déjà
commencé à écrire alors il y avait tout
de même un avantage parce que nous nous
distinguons le lot c'est le money
parfaite d'économie parfaite et s'ils
voulaient rentrer l'académie boulette de
riez je ne suis pas sûre que mon aide
suffirait à me faire entrer quand vous
avez été marin mais lui il ya peu plus
de 10 ans 11 ans maintenant
il a dit les à gré des missions se sont
trompés c'est moi qui voulais tu es
lions betfair phillies ont trompé de
perfides ces loteries santé ligue 1 je
crois que il y aurait quelques
difficultés mais je trouve que en temps
gris manier d'outré d'y entrer encore
vous étiez ministre de l'information
vous aviez d'ailleurs dans votre cabinet
j'ai appris ça je ne savais pas monsieur
contaminé monsieur hans qui était dans
votre dans le cabinet à l'époque quand
j'étais ministre de l'information
c'est vrai vous appeliez le patron du
journal télévisé pour lui demander son
sommaire c'est vrai que ça se faisait
jusque là c'est vrai que j'étais une 33e
ministre de la formation depuis la
guerre et depuis depuis
le premier jusqu'au dernier de ces 33
bis de l'information c'est ce qui se
faisait le journal télévisé se faisait
dans le bureau du ministre d'information
et quand mon prêt nécessaire m'a passé
des consignes va passer la main et il
m'a montré une batterie de sonnettes qui
était sur mon bureau alors lui me
permettais d'appeler le directeur
général l'autre directeur des journaux
le troisième but des acteurs de
télévision 4ème des fables à radio et
ainsi de suite
et on peut dire que ça m'a surpris quand
même sourit je m'attendais pas à ça et
je me suis dit c'est impossible je veux
j'avais été pendant dix ans quitte le
match j'avais vécu à l'étranger savait
comment les choses se passaient en
angleterre aux états-unis au canada
mind occidental aussi nous sommes un
pays occidental nous sommes un pays
libéral c'est pas possible qu'on fasse
comme dans l'esprit il aime rappeler
cracovie trois tableaux car oui
absolument et je me suis juré de faire
évoluer ce système
alors pendant les premiers temps puisque
j'étais dans le système et puis j'étais
de vrai patron de la radio et de
télévision il fallait que j'assume ces
fonctions les u n'ai rien eu de plus
près c'est que de préparer un nouveau
statut que j'ai fait voter en 264 ca sud
de l'office est le début jean télévision
française et j'ai imposé par la loi des
distances entre le gouvernement et 2
la radio et la télévision et à partir de
ce moment-là plus jamais le journal
télévisé le joint radio ne se sont faits
dans john oliveira le film vous avez été
victime il ya à peu près un an faisait
pas été victime a été la cible d'un
attentat dans quelques invoque
malheureusement été victime aujourd'hui
on arrêtait max frérot il nie avoir été
l'auteur de cet attentat
imaginez qu'un jour il avoue qu'on
arrive à prouver que qu'il était
l'auteur de cet attentat
est ce que vous pensez qu'il mérite la
peine de mort pour ça je ne pense pas
qu'ils héritent la mer noire pour avoir
essayé de me tuer si c'est lui qui l'a
fait puisqu'il n'a pas avoué par
parenthèse un terroriste qui rate son
affaire ne se vendent pas de la varappe
t il ya pas seulement les policiers du
fonds des bavures les terroristes auront
aussi la preuve ils veulent travailler
pour l'action d'être relax au
prolétariat mais puis il tue un
prolétaire c'est plutôt raté
c'est vraiment une bavure est donc max
frérot n'allait pas avouer cette bavure
tant qu'on ne peut pas l'approuver
donc ce n'est pas parce qu'il nie que ce
n'est pas lui qui l'a fait mais il est
possible que ce soit pas lui des
possibles d'ailleurs il n'avait sûrement
pas seul pour faire une filature pour
connaître des habitudes des gens il faut
6 et enfin que ce soit lui ou pas est-ce
que vous pensez que alors l'appel nama
c'est un problème qui reste ouvert
moi je pense que il a été très imprudent
de la part de mon successeur et de la
part du gouvernement 1980 de faire voter
la peine de mort contre le gré des
français le même jour où ce cette peine
de mort a été abolie
les deux tiers des français disaient
qu'ils étaient pour son maintien
on n'a pas le droit de violer un peuple
contre les démocrates
ça peut conduire la démagogie ça aussi
de nom parce que la démagogie
ça consiste à suivre les impulsions et
ça ce n'est pas une inflexion
car depuis dix ans de 1971 exactement
les français ont toujours manifesté avec
la même
continuité et sans aucune exception et
avec la même majorité des deux tiers
dont l'écrasante majorité ils étaient
pour le maintien derrière la barre alors
personnellement j'ai toujours été
eni blement impressionné par le fait que
dans un état civilisé ont pu
volontairement quelqu'un est donc la
peine de mort me fait horreur mais
j'estime et pendant les quatre ans que
j'étais garde des sceaux que je n'avais
pas le droit de prendre cette décision
ou de la faire prendre par le parlement
puisse qu'elle relevait du parlement
premièrement prudence bien simple ce qui
avait pas de majorité au parlement pour
la beauté et deuxièmement parce que je
trouvais que il ne fallait pas ôter aux
français ce qui était la clé de voûte de
leur système pénal et il est certain que
le sentiment d'insécurité n'a fait que
progresser depuis l'abolition de la
plupart des croyants
oui ça vous gêne pas en tant que
croyante assez favorable à la peine de
mort
là l'église catholique et le pape lui
même à plusieurs reprises ont dit qu'ils
étaient hostiles à la peine de mort si
elle n'était pas appliquée suivant des
règles équitables en donnant toute
garantie à l'inculpé à l'accusé et si
les jours j'étais pas fait de façon
parfaitement équitable mais ils n'ont
jamais condamné la peine de mort et des
évêques français ont très rapidement
mais l'église aparthotel le pape ne va
pas vous avez cet attentat vous a rendu
plus croyants le fait d'avoir échappé
est ce que vous y voyez une une présence
divine qu'on n'a pas eu d'effet on n'a
pas eu d'effet le penser que j'avais eu
la baraka
mais j'ai pensé aussi que un pauvre
innocent dans le mode innocent n'est pas
tout à fait approprié puisque j'étais
innocent si un homme qui était
totalement étranger à la lutte que j'ai
menée dans ma vie et donc au risque que
j'ai assumé jusque et le métier
politique est un métier à risque auris
mme c'était totalement injuste c'était
qui volent tankiste omar et si j'en veux
à matteo
houas ce terroriste ya fait cet attentat
ce n'est pas tellement de m'avoir pris
pour cible c'est d'avoir assassiné un
homme innocent alain peyrefitte nous
avons avec nous dominique jamet est ce
que dominique jamet donc s'est
singularisé dernièrement dans un journal
qui s'appelle globe a appelé françois
mitterrand à se représenter
bon petit qui lui a valu d'être viré
illico presto philippe tesson imaginons
que au figaro et un journaliste vous
êtes président du comité éditorial et un
journaliste comme ça qui est signé cet
appel dans globe en disant voilà il faut
que mitterrand se représente
est-ce que vous l'auriez foutu dehors je
dois dire que je comprends qu'il ait sa
liberté de mouvement et je comprends
aussi un directeur de journal qui
cherchent à obtenir que ses lecteurs et
trouve une cohérence dans ce journal
ou alors j'imagine que les lecteurs
paris ont été assez surpris de cette
profession de foi et je comprends
l'attitude de philippe tesson
la question ne s'est pas posée au figaro
à se poser un sérieux problème réponse
de diplomates mais voilà une réponse
quand même alors dominique non seulement
tu as dit qu'il fallait que mitterrand
se représente mais en plus j'avais écrit
une lettre ouverte dans le matin je
pense en disant à jacques chirac
il fallait pas qu'il se présente lui par
contre c'est qu'il ferait un bon maire
de paris mais que comme président de la
république c'était peut-être moins bien
alors on commence par là on commence par
où tu veux je ne sais pas non parce que
si effectivement j'ai écrit une lettre
ouverte à jacques chirac que quand lui
conseillant nous parle suppliant comment
mieux ces diamants en lui conseillant de
ne pas se présenter à la présidence de
la république ça découle est très
logiquement de l'engagement précédent
c'est à dire que je souhaite
effectivement que françois mitterrand se
représente à la présidence de la
république on retrouve en reparler je
crois au moment où nous parlons qu'il va
se représenter et je pense que s'il se
représente il se marrer c'est même
dominique jamais lui demande je pense
qu'il va le faire maintenant vous en
prie je vous en prie ne m'attribue pas
une influence que je n'ai nullement mais
dès l'instant que je pense qu'il va être
réunies tromper mais je crois qu'il va
être réélu donc que vous m'accorderez
très logiquement il va battre les
adversaires qui me sont proposés l'un de
ses deux adversaires c'est raymond barre
et le jour huit ou double président ou
rien
il n'est rien à l'heure actuelle oui je
dis quelque chose rien d'institutionnels
il n'est pas premier ministre il n'est
pas président d'un parti donc le risque
qu'il prend est énorme pour lui et c'est
jacques chirac au contraire à l'heure
actuelle est à la fois président du
parti le plus puissant de la majorité et
premier ministre chef du gouvernement de
la cohabitation
s'il se présente et qu'il est battu et
le raisonnement est extrêmement simple
il perd la légitimité qu'il a acquise en
mars quatre exercices en étant le
vainqueur des élections et une perte
impossible que quelqu'un qui a ainsi
perdu sa légitimité soit reconduit comme
chef du gouvernement
il me semble même qu'il met en danger
poste son statut de président du parc
une pulsion de majorité c'est donc en
toute l'année dit que je lui conseille
comme conseiller dans cet article de ne
pas se présenter et j'ai vu avec intérêt
d'ailleurs que si la chose est exact que
quelques-uns de ses conseillers parmi
les plus proches ensuite calé nom de
denis beaudoin de maurice ulrich
lyon conseiller également je ne sais pas
si c'est après avoir lu cet article si
c'est si l'on réfléchit par eux mêmes je
pense qu'ils sont capables de réfléchir
à l'om lui conseiller également de ne
pas faire cette faute si vous donnez à
jacques chirac
je conseille de ne pas se présenter
c'est parce qu'ils voulaient du bien et
si vous donnez à françois mitterrand le
congrès se présenter c'est que nous lui
voulait également du bien et bien en se
plaçant de ce point de vue là c'est à
dire bien différent je pense que vous
devez lui conseille de ne pas se
présenter pour deux raisons la première
c'est que contrairement à ce que veulent
étudier son élection n'est pas du tout
assurée pour le moment ils bénéficient
de ce destin de sacralisation que
comportent les institutions il est un
personnage au dessus des partis des
l'arbitré national c'est la continuité
de sa et les français ont parfaitement
compris l'esprit de cette constitution
et de ce régime
par conséquent il bénéficie sur sa
canonisation on s'incline devant lui
comme jadis en s'incliner devant les
empereurs chinois
mais à partir du moment où il est
candidat et non plus président sa
légitimité a disparu et il faut t'il
prouve qu'il pourrait être un bon
président une deuxième fois et alors ça
change complètement problème est
derrière souvenez-vous le général de
gaulle en novembre 1965 au début de la
campagne présidentielle était crédité
par l'ifop de 69 % des intentions de
vote et trois semaines après les 60 9%
c'est terrible à 44% que le jce 80 et
giscard ça recommence à 80 autrement dit
la période de la campagne électorale est
une période terrible de désacralisation
le roi est nu
ce n'est plus le roi
frima vers l'afrique dans le capital
ghoga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec
gainsbourg parce qu'il a fait la photo
de ton disque izïa fait deux chansons
qui s'appelait casbah et l'autre était
consacré de lui oui comment ça s'est
passé le travail
baho nouveau travail serait génial
c'était une collaboration artistique
tontine intéressante pour moi j'étais
fan tu l'a rencontré comme à turin vente
résister le voir ni moment c'est une
sanction sur un de mes textes il se
trouve que ce texte et ça plaît il à
dire et je vais pas très funky et
ensuite c'était quand même coïncidence
il s'appelait du dieu je suis sortie
avec lui dans pas mal de boateng
j'ai lu beaucoup de goals and within une
aventure alors comment il allait très
bien il est très bien puisqu'il doit il
peut très bien longtemps avant quand je
bois pas savoir ils la suivent sa
validation même quand il boit et la
sienne à bord pas spécialement au niveau
affectif au boulot boulot moi je ne vois
pas encore assurée aux lignes d'eau
douce assez
ça c'est le privé ça n'arrivait pas à me
demander une aventure avec moi j'ai pas
envie de parler des histoires sexuelles
avec un sport confirme quand même plutôt
encore assuré je confie passionne
alizèta des risques et maintenant je
vais cracher dans les parcs et en
montrer le jour soit un plateau de télé
3d un enfant les informations en visite
dans ce cas pas chez nous on n'est pas
fâchés ça faisait partie d'un moment
comme ça pendant 2 3 mois c'était un
parcours initiatique pour moi de
rencontrer ses lecteurs
et puis ensuite bon j'ai des choses à
faire mais aussi et voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de quoi web en champagne c'est bon on va
pouvoir c'est ce que tu as sur toi
[Musique]
soit
qui nous mener
loi du monde fait les bordelais mais
et puis
[Musique]
mais la gaze et de marais
rappelons que la cave nous publié chez
laffont un livre qui s'appelle t à
l'opium que j'ai lu j'ai beaucoup aimé
parce que je trouve qu'ils soient
rapidement extraordinaire alors vous
êtes originaire d'italie d'une famille
ces bourgeois et émouvant oui j'étais au
courant des dames en grève à m
il convient tout d'abord de gagner ce
qu'ils fabriquent un de paepe lé pape a
appelé les rats c'est à dire pions et
quand vous étiez petit j'étais très ami
avec les fils de buts souligné
j'étais comment les fils de mission au
sein des bagarres sont tous les deux on
était dans ma classe a au lycée et on
s'amusait bien
la villa torlonia la maison de son père
on faisait des faits on allait à cheval
eu quelques points et on sait bien sûr
36 élus père nous rencontrions 200
enfants bientôt trois scènes mondiales
hors canton à vip est en train jeunes et
venez nous voir la vidéo
c'est pas pour moi c'est pas pour moi
avant d'accord j'étais gentil
oh oui très à l'aise alors un jouet
c'est là que votre vie bascule
complètement
vous rencontrez un général résister pas
général à l'époque c'était un officier
de tchang kaï-chek il dit en italie et
qui s'appelle monsieur tam
il fait ses études en italie c'était aux
chinois qu'ils effectuent dans little
miss fr moyer par les boulonnais machine
voilà il après ton serait vite militaire
avital voilà et alors vous le rencontrez
votre vie bascule de tomber complètement
amoureuse de lui
oui vous vous sentez que c'est votre
c'est votre amour quoi tout de suite
kapadia pas de discussion c'est le coup
de foudre
halte au feu alors c'est quand même un
sacré nous votre muse souhaitable parce
que le jour de votre 8,9 vous partez en
voiture et vous amène dans un hôtel et
ils ont fait boire du thé à l'opium
ça vous a pas surpris ça mais je l'aimé
tellement léger des six jeunes que je
voulais faire parce que ça leur exemple
et ridha ben oui j'aurais bien aimé vous
rencontrez vous avez quel âge à l'époque
où vous viviez dit elle
mais vos copines c'était pas comme vous
quand même bien que vous luttez comme ça
c'est exceptionnel quand même content ce
temps là il y avait des femmes avaient
déjà inscrit te plaît comme d'hab on
sait qu'ils avaient envie d'exotisme à
oui mais ça n'est pas le temps c'est pas
le cas vous partez en chine
je suis arrivé là bas j'ai déploré que
vous faites des enfants d'abord j'ai
fait beaucoup d'enfants beaucoup enfin
j'aimerais avec les chinois je fais dans
ma les chinois n'aiment pas de sept 7
ans et vous découvrez que finalement bon
en dehors du coton et cultive l'opium
cela vous choque pas beaucoup mais c'est
un truc est très étonnant dans votre lit
que c'est que finalement tout ça vous
arrive mais bon vous voyez ça il vise
yeux d'enfant vous n'avez pas vraiment
de jugement moral de jugement
l'éducation des bonnes soeurs mais je
n'avais pas tellement marqué non sa
veine en particulier des lampions j'aime
la manière lors pulsar est un jour de
2009 ce que vous avez pris le thé le
club ne savais pas que c'était d'opium
on connaissait par leur permettra comme
un ange ouais non non on ne sait pas du
tout fait pas tout à fait une chose des
faits m'oriente pas c'est une drôle
d'histoire vous arriver là vous faites
les enfants est lui parti de suite à la
guerre qui vous laisse t on là vous avez
ya une chose qui est assez étonnant
d'ailleurs c'est qu'un jour vous êtes
endormi on peut pas vraiment dormi vous
pleuré un peu de terreau de triche je
trouve être marié pas là et il ya la
servante qui s'approche de vous la base
qui s'approche de vous et qui commencent
à vous faire des calibres et un peu
partout pas qui se termine quand vous
êtes aperçu après que la mère ne savait
alors oui je pensais je sais pas ce qui
désoriente om sera parce que j'en ai ma
vie n'est pas là et la femme a besoin
estime-t-il d'amour d'affection était
seule chose c'est une chose même si
biologique est alors une autre femme que
ça au lieu de deux hommes ça vous a plu
vous avez recommencé à bien commencé
mais après ça tourne mal toute cette
histoire parce que bon vous le suivez
offrons d'habiter dans une petite maison
avec lui les en bois puis je sais pas ce
qui se passe un jour vous apercevez que
qui vous prend pas avec une infirmière à
ce moment là vous faites un truc sous
serre que vous allez à shanghai s'est
pas amusé il à l'époque assez
extraordinaire il adore depuis une très
belle description de shanghai qui est
partagé à l'époque entre les différents
pays d'europe avec délégation avec les
quartiers qui ça
c'est un bilan fantastique on peut même
pas la comparer à la new york
d'aujourd'hui n'est ce pas c'était
le quelque chose d'extraordinaire ou des
jambes et de l'argent des gens qui
étaient là
enfin la bagarre mais quand même
je devrais rester là parce que le sel
ville qui voulait avait été réduit en
cendres
mais les installer à l'hôtel d'abord
dans un dans un bel hôtel à l'impérial
qui ensuite dans un hôtel un peu moins
un peu moins cher y alors il ya une amie
à vous qui s'appelle même si c'est ça
non et oui un démon qui vous dit voilà
on va ouvrir un restaurant laloux et
tout un étage et vous ouvrez un
restaurant et nous organiser comme ça tu
disais vous fait rencontrer des gens oui
et elle était déjà l'effet des jardins
le gouvernement sino-japonais dans les
temps et faisait des dîners organisés de
dîner un peu des ambassades déjà cool
pour aborder les dents des subventions
qui est intéressant dans vos clips c'est
justement la guerre la deuxième guerre
mondiale vue de lorient c'est à dire on
voit comme ça effectivement les japonais
qui ont envahi la pratiquement tout
l'extrême orient à commencer par là par
la chine que les japonais et à écrire
qu'il a les caméras que des amandiers
les amendes et en italien sur le port de
montréal il a mal fait des semaines et
je pense que
les japon les japonais m'ont dit tu dois
donner les airs des informations à ce
que tu laissais on peut le savoir
d'autres fonctions mais alors qu'un
somalien a réglé tous à l'art c'est
votre côté notre avis c'est à dire que
là vous commencez à il ya un truc quand
même qu'il faut dire c'est que il vous
arrive souvent dans ce restaurant de
finir la nuit avec des clients comme m
oui parce qu'ils étaient des gens que je
fais un tour et à subir des mouches et
des déformations alors j'étais obligé
vous avez les informations en étant
mieux quand on est marié commandant oui
c'est ça mais est ce que vous regrettez
aujourd'hui de remplacer toutes ses
nuits avec tous ces hommes que vous
puissiez pas trop bien servi par ribéry
toujours ça c'est un peu dur quand même
comme époque l'an l'époque et maintenant
alors pas maintenant les policiers la
nuit avec des japonais également des
français
dans ce temps-là je m'en tombent mais
c'est un sacrifice je n'avais pas moyen
de faire d'autre alors après la fin de
l'ère il ya des bombes atomiques qui
tombe sur japon donc tout s'arrête et la
faisait quand même des problèmes qu'on
accuse
on pense la libération disons j'avais
été condamné en tant qu on allait que
j'étais en prison
j'étais impuissant et après je passais
de la fourrer tribunal militaire à bas
et précis wilaya après j'étais condamné
à mort ce tube de la mort met en prison
des boues
il y est quand même en prison de trouver
un joli joli japonais je n'ai pas donné
un petit bassin on croyait même plage
avant j'ai fait l'amour avec mon mari je
vais notre foi et bien et 16e des pnj le
consul français sont aux fruits atteinte
trafic et de l'os comment la wii peuvent
dire j'ai eu un destin extraordinaire
s'est tenu toute cette histoire
cinq étages - alors je veux venir
pourrait permettre dans le fait d'avoir
vu ça si vous êtes là c'est que vous
êtes un peu le même style
alors avant tout j'ai pour toi vous dis
et je suis pas de ces planètes japonais
qui s'intéressent au mondial année en
france extrait alors ton mec sain
terrestre confejes je peux dire que j'ai
300 présents des chansons présentes oui
c'est ça mais quand je viens de l'autre
hémisphère j'espère que son départ
les équipes est de mise
merci bien 4 vais très bien alors
maintenant on va voir une séquence qui
s'appelle album cd ce qu'un photographe
s'appelle sylvain bergère qui va dans
toutes les boîtes de nuit paris et qui
photographient les gens qui s'amusent
c'est ça c'est le best-of de l'année
c'est les meilleures photos de l'année
regardez ça vous rappelle des souvenirs
[Musique]
ça commence à montmartre avec popeye ça
continue avec le de l'ours est l'auteur
des cinq dernières minutes toujours
montmartre le vistre rue saint denis
on joue aux boules à la cave laferrière
de nîmes corps la feria des vendanges
[Musique]
il
les gipsy kings
on s'amuse
non
en
défilé christian lacroix
défilé d'eric bergeron
on
francis bacon galerie lelong
sylvie squinazi exposé au bain quand
elle pose pas chez lacroix et les
véhicules rue du faubourg-saint-antoine
la fiac au grand palais le palace mballa
ce moment rare
et
là j'aurai le lapin
serait il faut avoir du temps le salon
rue saint-honoré
c'est fermé
les trottoirs de buenos aires et rue des
lombards christian vander à l'excalibur
le john carlos bruma sa vie
mais ça les rues d'al anbar
l'escale rue monsieur le prince
raging bull peinture
le flashback pop-up rue des quatre-vents
la java rue du faubourg du temple
5e avenue avenue foch le studio a rue de
ponthieu à côté de chez régis leurs ex
vouloir poissonnier la nouvelle fontaine
le royallieu rue des italiens
non
le bataclan boulevard voltaire on peut
amener les enfants merci plus guère
distrito corti le mardi rue berger
hardy fesses dans ses pires moments
oh
ubi le fiancé de marie cesnek claude
challe et les chouchous des années 80 tu
sais tu ce que vous voyez là c'est un
talk show là où rires ouais alors
commencer un talk show alors tu dis par
exemple jean pierre kalfon
bonsoir boris bergman bonsoir vous venez
de sortir c'est le mec une telle claque
à nice 1 alors mais de sortir un disque
l'amour à lagord et qu'est vachement
bien
c'est quoi l'amour à la donne c'est un
peuple alors bah je vais dire que je les
ai déjà beaucoup d alors je vais laisser
leur histoire vraie morale comme si une
petite chanson jean pierre a eu l'idée
au départ au départ pour nous c'était
bon là l'obligation de mettre des petits
chapeaux alors qu'on n'en mettais pas
mettez chapon albert voilà ils passaient
directement passer la douane après que
je travaille sans abri et ça nous posait
des problèmes puis c'était aussi l'amour
à la mort il ya tout eu 20 ans de petite
liberté sexuelle qui vont partir en
fumée quoi il est une très belle phrase
compote
il dit que c'est l'endroit où qui
donnait la vie et maintenant c'est
l'endroit qui peut donner la mort c'est
en avant avant on va attraper la vie
voilà ce qu'on peut attendre voilà alors
après 20 ans
libération voilà
mais il ya des gens il ya six mois et à
9 mois il ya un an on a commencé le
plein de pubs et où beaucoup de gens qui
m'appelaient pour savoir moi le cadre
libre ouais qu'est ce que je vais faire
maintenant
well as maté membres et la tête et puis
il y avait plein d'histoires d'exorciser
là et ça me donne une idée de ce titre
qui obstruent traitement bien avec eux
l'amour bidan à l'album
c'est aussi là la série facile c'est pas
de la gueule non
c'est évident comme on disait à l'école
classique noyon ya on rentre dans une
époque où les fruits qu'à la femme à
devenir un peu vidanger choses
deviennent un peu bidon il faut le dire
un nouveau truc tueur alors avec quoi il
ya d'autres façons de faire l'amour dès
qu'on parle de l'amour moderne
oui il ya quoi le minitel way and
minutes non moi je si je vois pas les
gens je peux pas que toi je suis déjà en
garde et par déjà au téléphone n'était
jamais fait non mais aussi faux que je
touche la carte de crédit vous avez fait
le truc où on donne son numéro et on
peut parler alors la [ __ ] la
dominatrice
je suis pas sûr que je vais pas tomber
sur une vieille
avec ce succès vieille qu'un train de
tricoter comme ça qu'il eut un taxi
c'est un peu comme les [ __ ] à l'ombre
des 30 mètres dehors
la superbe forme qui en bas et qu'ils en
main gauche est vraiment là tu vois des
objets pas mal d'informations sur les
routes par des copains comme toi par
exemple ils vont et qui vois et
j'entends beaucoup parler de ça puis je
sais qu'ils tombent pas toujours sur des
camions quoi est ce que vous croyez pas
maintenant que le que le fait que les
coupes sont obligés d'être fidèle ça va
être un retour en force des objets les
codes et tout ça ça parvenir ça je crois
que ça marcherait avec quelqu'un d'autre
jours qu'ils voulaient
qui voulait créer un club devant l'aide
voilà est ainsi par exemple anne bonne
idée alors disons que c'est la
libération des sexes qu'on a obtenus
mais la libération de l'amour pour le
moment on dire déjà poindre ou quoi la
méfiance qui sème les âmes ainsi amener
d'autres installent de plus en plus
qu'ailleurs plus de plus en plus de
sollicitations
ouais les affiches partout qu'on veut
dire qu'avec toujours jeune gerald vie
mais cela a réalisé à les épidermes
dernier on était votre chapeau bas
comme on dit
je vais mais pour sauver la face à une
telle formule dati aussi des belles
formules c'était quand tu disais c'est
la vie canada dry bien sans la couleur
de la vie le coût de la vie mais ces
deux pays séparés si ça ouais c'est bien
mais je mettais pas l'avion féminin
lui offrant que cette semaine et
chouchou c'est sans espoir
c'est cuit comment tu veux qu'ils
trouvent un chouchou l'année passée
cuisse et rappelé il serra mais pas un
thé pas sur cette [ __ ] il faut poser
la question n'y a pas de vrais droits
d'auteur ou des chutes et toi faut selon
lui la question franck on verra bien si
ça pose la question à l'époque personne
que des chouchous il allait sur sud et
l'inter mais je vous avais pensé à tous
je m'étais dit que si un jour n'était ce
militaire
si j'avais une pâte et oui je les vagues
souvenirs la nina simone c'est le
premier que je fais alors comme dans un
club régis valliot et ça c'est le
dernier que qu'est sorti à bari à cause
de la pub chanel de tout le monde
connaîtra finalement inch'allah je vous
aime voilà il ya billy joel en cinq ans
la cnaf verse en liga ces deux là
si on connaissait alexis boeuf ou alexis
qui malgré justement la rencontre phare
est et à roland giresse acer je me tiens
génère la belle juliette je te quitte
rennes et puis voilà je vienne mais je
crois savoir la marge puisque on
n'arrive à rien d'autre à manger voilà
il a amené la cassonade à la dgos à la
casse
voilà c'est bon pote avec 6 10 mois est
ce que tu te voir un climat c'est moi
j'aimerai te voir plus grand
vous allez voir le clip qui s'appelle my
baby just cares for me boulay il a 6
mois un manchot sur oasis au asie
[Musique]
jean jacques beineix tu fais quoi en ce
moment je travaille avec mon petit mon
mac intosh j'écris c'est vrai que tu vas
tu intéressés à des choses plus à des
mythes à des grands mythes des grands
thèmes les choses plus éternel derrière
les anecdotes il ya des choses qu'on
voudrait essayer de comprendre
commencent à s'apercevoir que à 40 ans
on a au moins tout fait au moins deux
fois et on peut continuer comme ça il ya
un moment où on pousse on se pose quand
même la question de savoir s'il ya pas
quelque chose d'autre mais j'ai pas vu
pas encore trouvé je vais pas te le dire
ce soir
alors tu avais prédit 120 130 millions
de spectateurs au cinéma pour 87 7 ans
86 pour 88 tu vois quoi à peu près j'ai
bien peur que ça tombe encore un peu
c'est pas comme la bourse mais presque
c'est la faute à qui c'est parce qu'à
plus de stars où il ya plus de
producteurs non je crois que c'est là je
crois que c'est pas il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas une seule raison il ya plein de
raisons
je crois que c'est une je crois que le
cinéma il est en train de vieillir
ouais je crois que bon il ya les
télévisions il ya le cinéma il ya la
crise du cinéma français c'est pas une
crise du cinéma américain c'est pas été
la crise la plus grave c'est celle du
cinéma français donc je pense que c'est
conjoncturel il ya un moment difficile à
passer
il ya un avenir pour le cinéma mais le
cinéma c'est quand même un art qui est
en train de vieillir
on va de plus en plus vite les images
sont partout
nous les gens de cinéma on est un peu
vieux jeu il ya des fois je me demande
si on n'est pas un peu comme des mecs
qui ont rêvé d'être des cap horniers au
moment où les premiers bateaux à vapeur
arrive et moi je ne changerai pas je
continuerai à faire le cap horn mais je
pense qu'on va se prendre comme à la
barre assez haut dans la tranche était
ambitions américaines aujourd'hui
jusqu'à quand même eu l'échec de chauves
souris tout est parti à new york un
échec
c'est un film qui était très cher on
donne pas une grenouille
ouais un film de 20 millions de dollars
ou alors il faut du temps il va leur
falloir du temps mais j'étais
pratiquement arrivé à en été on avait le
stylo à la main
j'étais à la columbia avec david potsdam
qui était un espoir pour tous les
artistes qui existe outre atlantique et
au moment où on allait signer be s'est
pas tu perds pas espoir
mais pas du tout non non je veux faire
de le faire sur pied je vais faire ce
film parce que si ce film se fait pas ça
veut dire que le cinéma existe plus or
comme le cinéma existe encore il va se
faire entendre avec le pognon parce que
divassa quand même p o 10 millions de
dollars 37 2 a dû en faire deux ou trois
tu as beaucoup d'argent je veux ta ville
toujours à clichy moi je sais pas je te
voir en photo c'est à clichy dans un
petit appartement
ça fait un peu penser à mondino parce
que jean bad comme ça il faut gagner pas
mal de pognon ils habitent toujours dans
des endroits un bon tu vois que il n'y a
pas de fatalité
non c'est je crois que ça se fait en a
pas parce que tu te mets en revanche
bien non je crois que c'est surtout
je préfère tout le poignon de tous ses
films il ya plein de mecs dans le monde
entier qu'ils me doivent pas qu'il doive
doivent aux films que j'ai faits leur
rôle leur machine
moi je commençais à gagner de l'argent
disons depuis depuis un an et demi deux
ans et j'ai surtout gagner de l'argent
avec la pub peut-être je gagnerai un
jour de l'argent avec le cinéma
c'est pas la finalité de la chose pour
moi c'est pas la finalité ou si je gagne
de l'argent
c'est pour un jour peut-être même payé
vraiment le film que j'ai envie de me
payer pour pas avoir l'humiliation
d'avoir à demander l'argent à des gens
j'aime pas me sentir une danse j'aime
pas qu'on dise aux artistes on va vous
donner le droit de faire un film occupe
et surtout vous occupez rien d'autre
faites votre feed j'aime pas ça parce
que les artistes d'aujourd'hui c'est des
gens qui ont compris que dans l'époque
actuelle pour faire la guerre il fallait
des canons mais il fallait pas laisser à
des bureaucrates le soin d'acheter les
canons il faut s'acheter soi même ses
propres canaux tout acheter un bateau
quand même oui je me suis acheté un
bateau il ya quatre ans c'est ma soeur
la richesse et il est beau il est blanc
ils en créent ou là ce soir il est à
gruissan c'est là on a tourné 37,2 et
c'est bien plus là sur ce bateau pendant
ma maman je forme et je joue comme un
jeu précis arrivée jean marin quel mal
de mer mais tu vas aux caraïbes avec non
c'est sûr mais quand des bateaux avant
l'averse comme ça ils suivent les alizés
j'ai failli faire cette année thierry
lhermitte m'avait proposé de partir avec
lui mais je veux être je vais te mon
patron sur mon bateau je vais être le
capitaine de mon bateau je me contente
de la méditerranée j'ai commencé avec
l'atlantic j'ai fait le tour j'étais aux
açores portugal c'est déjà bien
et puis là j'ai depuis trois ans je suis
en méditerranée j'ai fait j'ai pas été
partout mais j'étais dans plein
d'endroits la méditerranée c'est une
belle mère belle mère tu pars avec les
appels présentés cet été tous les deux
ouais
elle a pas eu de chance cette année
parce qu'on sait on sait on sait manger
une méchante tempête mais elle a bien
bien sûr et stable
non non je t'ai pas malade mais c'était
assez impressionnant des vagues immenses
la nuit
ce bateau bouge énormément c'est très
impressionnant en plus on entend des
voix pourra entendre des chants et de
filet chez blizzard il est donc un
capitaine de bateau à céret et nous
avons assez charmant il nous a sauvé
vous allez vous marier à perdre et des
soeurs nées déjà financé moi je suis
fiancée si je vais bientôt de barrières
non c'est bien là bas j'allais avoir un
enfant et tout bah ouais messieurs c'est
la totale vérité et plus tu vas faire
tourner dans des films à bec soient tous
les grands cinéastes comme ça on eu
leur égérie c'est ça c'est parti comme
ça elle va tourner dans roselyne et les
lions ouais elle va faire brosserie mais
elle est où la pas l'air comme ça mais
tous les jours elle est allée dans la
cage avec les lions tous les jours ils
ont pas perdre des millions d'oiseaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais
je
aller plus haut
je suis seul dans l'univers j'ai peur du
ciel et de l'hiver
qui part vers ce qui compte le plus
cadeau didon alors tu as beaucoup galéré
quand même avant de faire l'homme de la
manche quand tu as fait des faits des
animations club med des animations chez
cruiser chez paquet chez costa dont
c'était dur tout ça qu'est ce qui leur
faisait par exemple
aujourd'hui je faisais des jeux le
raconter les histoires et organiser les
spectacles mais j'étais plus du côté du
spectale et a fait des trucs dans les
hôtels haut sinon la négraille
hinterland sheraton j'ai fait les
croisières paquet et puis après c'est
thibault va pas fait ça combien de temps
avant de faire peur j'ai fait cinq par
cinq en cinq ans et après j'ai fait un
tour du monde avec mon one-man-show qui
était composé de sketches de chansons et
surtout de claquettes
après hugues ouvrard après boire
heureusement qu'il était là et puis a eu
ce grand moment dans la dans la
farandole enfin non à l'époque c'était
carnaval dans le carnaval de celanese il
ya tout à fait fabius qui s'est énervé
contre chirac ait joué par sébastien et
toi tu faisais la poule tu sais comment
la pole mais comment tu sais
[Musique]
j'ai étudié les poules pendant des
années tu fais bien moi je te laissais
faire pour une pub
ah oui c'était toi oui bien sûr c'est
l'âme de la manche oui et ça ça va à
l'étranger parce que ce rôle là je pense
que beaucoup de gens l'attendent et je
veux dire c'est un spectacle qui qui
m'apporte beaucoup de choses beaucoup
beaucoup de plaisir et comme jean pliya
l'a dernièrement à une émission de
télévision c'est un spectacle où il
jouait lviv on est content de le jouer
il ya une troupe extraordinaire alors
c'est l'homme de la manche de des lois
sur man dans l'adaptation a été faite
par jacques brel à lime rock 1
on croyait qu'on le verrait plus jamais
parce que bon une fois que jacques brel
était mort on s'est dit on ne verra plus
jamais ce truc là un gros morceau c'est
jean luc tardieu café la mise en scène
on est dans une très très rigide par et
oui la ffj anne-claire l'année dernière
chan clare est avec
chez le roi y est vous avez commencé à
jouer la jouer un peu plus d'un mois et
on a joué quelques jours à orléans et
angers ça s'est très bien passé
c'est très bien placés parce que c'est
un spectacle qui est pour tout public
c'est pas je dirais pour les gens dont
quelque chose c'est un peu rébarbatif et
c'est un spectacle c'est une comédie
musicale est un spectacle qui est très
ouvert à tous les publics et les deux
spectacles ont marché le mieux s'arrêter
spectacle de danse pour l'épauler pour
les étudiants de 14 à 20 ans et c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vois des
gosses de 14 20 ans en standing ovation
c'est à dire qu'à la fin du spectacle
dédié au bout la larme à l'oeil en train
d'applaudir et ça c'est le plus grand
que c'est bien pensé à marigny après
après belmondo non oui juste après kim
c'est à dire que
belmondo a arrêté le 3 et nous on
attaque le 15 pour toi tu fais sancho
pancha qui fait don quichotte cervantes
c'est jean piat ouais c'est pas mal ah
oui c'est sûr c'est énorme pour moi de
travailler avec un personnage aussi
important parce qu'ils aient une
maîtrise une certitude c'est fantastique
et puis jeane manson qui joue le rôle de
dulcinée à londres et puis je répèterai
pas encore mais enfin je n'aurais peut
être pas suffisamment mais toute la
troupe qui est qui est extraordinaire
parce qu'il ya des cascadeurs des
danseurs des chanteurs
il ya une musique extraordinaire qui
dirigé par un grand chef d'orchestre qui
s'appelle olivier holt est très jeune
qu'à 27 ans est tout tout leur caisse
est très très jeune je voyais une
homogénéité extraordinaire pour toi
c'est une date quand même parce qu'après
toutes ces galères et tout ces jeux
souffle ouais je souffre parce qu'on a
besoin de ce genre de spectacle
on a besoin de ce genre de rôle et là
j'arrive à travers sont chaudes de
pouvoir jouer de pouvoir m'exprimer
physiquement et ça c'est très important
on n'a pas souvent l'occasion de pouvoir
s'exprimer dans une pièce de théâtre on
fait toujours des petites choses mais là
c'est vraiment
ouais je chante c'est à dire que j'ai eu
beaucoup de difficulté à chanter
le rôle de sancho parce que moi je suis
baryton et le rôle de la partition a été
écrite pour ténor donc j'étais obligée
de travailler comme comme jean un peu
plus trop quatre mois est lui un peu
plus de six mois
non pas parce que parce que lui il avait
pas beaucoup l'habitude de chanter moi
j'ai l'habitude de chanter mais avec un
micro et dans ce spectacle on chante
sans micro c'est que nous on chantait tu
peux nous enchanter un bout là comme si
c'est vers la loge avant de rentrer en
scène aller voter et moi je suis saint
just en chevalet sophie son frère eh
bien on va voir l'extrait maintenant
l'avouer un extrait du lot de la manche
merci impitoyable sans rétro tu es tombé
trop bas
donc tu es trop laid abominable regard
droit à chevalier de défis oui je suis
le kebab et célèbre la femme chat pour
toujours on services de l'honneur car
j'ai l'honneur d'être un chevalier sans
peur et le fond tu resteras en emprunts
ailleurs qu importe l'histoire
pourvu qu'elle mène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et j'en suis fier
alors serge loupien libération alors
c'est quoi cette histoire de maïs qui
joue les beatles ça vient de vous s'en
va ça vient de nouer ses terres au
moment de la fête de la musique on leur
a proposé de donner un concert à la
grande halle de la villette sur un
répertoire exclusivement beatles parce
que ça correspondait à peu près au 25e
anniversaire de la sortie de sergent
pepper il était un petit peu réticent au
départ parce que c'est pas tellement
leur truc les beatles eux c'est plutôt
le côté noir de la musique en angleterre
rolling stones etc
et puis finalement ils ont accepté le
concert s'est très bien passé un disque
est sorti chez mme ute de ce concert est
en fait un nouveau groupe et n'est
pratiquement scellé rowling beatles dire
qu'ils ont ils ont sali ce parce qu'on
avait un petit peu près vu ça ils ont
sali le répertoire beatles en
noircissant mexico c'est vrai quand on
était petits y avait ce qu'aimer les
beatles et ce qu'aimer les rolling
stones
moi j'étais plutôt de ce qu'aimer
debitel ce soir c'est la grande
réconciliation alors c'est la grande
réconciliation d'ailleurs ils sont
jamais été fâché ou même
non
ça
la honte
à
mais pas
oui
[Musique]
enfin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
là
[Applaudissements]
vous aurez à payer
là
voilà
lui verse aux oreilles
le
opinion way
alors mon figaro
[Musique]
b
non
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir
[Musique]
pire
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
ah ah
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
oui
traitant
mais l'ol sait pas
ah ah
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu